[Música]
si tratas de pagar algo con un pedazo de
papel puede que te encuentres con
algunos problemas a menos por supuesto
que el pedazo de papel sea un billete de
100 dólares pero que hace que ese
billete sea tanto más valioso que otros
pedazos de papel después de todo no es
mucho lo que puedes hacer con él
no puedes comerlo no puedes construir
cosas con él y quemarlo es ilegal
entonces por qué es tan especial por
supuesto probablemente conoces la
respuesta un billete de 100 dólares está
impreso por el gobierno y designado como
moneda oficial mientras otros pedazos de
papel no pero eso es sólo lo que los
hace legales lo que le da valor a un
billete de 100 dólares por otro lado es
si hay muchos o pocos en circulación a
lo largo de la historia el valor de la
mayoría de las divisas incluido el dólar
americano dependía del valor de las
materias primas y de la cantidad de
billetes en circulación pero luego de
que estados unidos aboliera ese sistema
en 1971 el dólar se convirtió en lo que
conocemos como moneda fiduciaria o sea
no relacionada con ningún recurso
externo sino que sólo depende de las
políticas de gobierno para decidir
cuánto
imprimir que parte del gobierno
estableció estas políticas el ejecutivo
el legislativo o el judicial ninguno de
los anteriores de hecho la política
monetaria es establecida por el
independiente sistema de reserva federal
conocido como la fed y compuesto por 12
bancos regionales en las ciudades más
grandes del país su consejo de
gobernadores que es nombrado por el
presidente y confirmado por el senado
reporta el congreso y todas las
ganancias de la fed van al tesoro de
eeuu pero para asegurar que la fed no
responda a la influencia de las
vicisitudes políticas del día a día no
está bajo el del control directo de
ninguna parte del gobierno entonces
porque la fe no decide imprimir
infinitos billetes de 100 dólares para
hacer a todos felices y ricos bueno
porque entonces los billetes no valdrían
nada
piensa en el propósito de la moneda si
todo el dinero en circulación crece más
rápido que el valor total de bienes y
servicios en la economía entonces cada
porción individual podría comprar una
porción más pequeña que antes esto se
llama inflación por otro lado si la
oferta de dinero se mantiene igual
mientras más bienes y servicios se
producen el valor de cada dólar
aumentaría en un proceso llamado
deflación cuál es peor demasiada
inflación significa que el dinero en tu
billetera hoy valdrá menos mañana
haciendo que quieras gastar la de
inmediato mientras esto estimula los
negocios también fomenta el consumo
excesivo o el acaparamiento de productos
como la comida y el combustible lo cual
aumenta los precios y genera escasez de
bienes e incluso más inflación pero la
deflación hará que la gente quiera
guardar su dinero disminuyendo el
consumo y reduciendo las ganancias de
los negocios esto genera más desempleo y
una mayor reducción en el gasto haciendo
que la economía siga decreciendo aunque
la mayoría de los economistas creen que
tanto la inflación como la deflación son
peligrosos en exceso es necesaria para
incentivar el crecimiento económico
la fed usa una gran cantidad de
información económica para determinar
cuánto dinero debería estar en
circulación tasas previas de inflación
tendencias internacionales y la tasa de
desempleo como en el cuento dígitos de
oro y los tres osos tienen que ajustar
los números al límite para poder
estimular el crecimiento y mantener a la
gente empleada sin permitir que la
inflación llegue a niveles perjudiciales
la fed no sólo determina el valor de ese
papel en tu billetera sino también tu
probabilidad de obtener o conservar el
trabajo donde ganas ese dinero